domi my first question is for you when
it comes to turning red it feels like a
very personal story i think um
especially for me as a chinese-american
there are a lot of moments that felt
like familiar and maybe too familiar
um i want to know when it comes to
writing the story and creating this
story what kind of journey did you go on
and did you pull from any of your own
personal life experiences
yeah yeah uh i definitely did i mean i
was may when i was 13 like i
uh was going through these big changes
and these mood swings and fighting with
my mom like almost every day and not
understanding why
uh and
and you know making this movie is kind
of my attempt to kind of go back in time
and kind of figure out like what was
going on with me but also what was going
on with my mom at the same time and try
to understand
our relationship and try to understand
her a lot better
um
yeah and then i think it was also
important for us to explore this
like specific story of an immigrant kid
of an asian kid and her relationship
with her mom because it's different it's
different than all been a lot of like
western stories where
you know the kid is like rebellious from
the beginning and and wants to do this
thing and wants to be independent and
hates their parent and and the parent is
like an obstacle like a militant kind of
uh wall that that that
whose mind needs to be changed in order
for the kid to break free and stuff but
you know like like for us like for for
me like i
loved you know my mom i i like with may
in the movie like uh she is super close
with her mom in the beginning they they
they spend so much time together
like uh cleaning the temple together
they're like each other's best friends
so there's
this
uh this this like sadness when when when
may is like growing into a different
person and kind of leaving behind her
her family a little bit like she doesn't
want to but she kind of is almost forced
to because of life and the way growing
up works so i kind of want to explore
that that that nuance and that uh
struggle of a of an asian kid amazing
well i thought it was really accurate
and it felt very real and i really i
like that it's not like mom versus
daughter you know like they have that
like really strong bond like you said
but also this you know obviously like
she the mom like ming has her own
generational you know trauma from her
mom that she
you know passed on to her daughter i
like that moment when she's like where
did she get that from and her husband's
like your mom's on the phone she's like
oh my god i'm not here
yes yeah i got a lot of laughs from a
lot of people on the crew they're like
yes
it's too real
and uh lindsay so my question for you
i've having worked on you know as a
producer for a lot of pixar projects i
want to know
what project that you worked on
presented the biggest challenge and
helped you grow as you know as a
producer well i think i mean it's it's a
little it's a little convenient to say
this one but i honestly it did i i think
you know in the same way that i at john
carter i produced which was a live
action my first time producing that
um was super challenging because it had
me re it had me rethinking the way i do
things and questioning and having to
kind of
um change my change my my native
language so to speak um and i think uh
for this one it was you know working
with domi was so different i mean she
comes
um at things very differently than than
other directors i've worked with she's
um she challenged she has good questions
and challenges things and um and it was
great because it made me kind of have to
sit back and and question i'm like do i
just do that because i've always done
that or is there a good reason behind um
what i'm what i'm suggesting and then
obviously the pandemic came and
you know i think pixar's over the years
and has gotten really good at making
movies not that the creative has gotten
stale or that we're good at like
figuring the stories out but the making
of them we've gotten really good at it
right everybody's so talented and
they're really you know capable and then
all of a sudden it was like oh
no everybody go home we have no idea
what we're doing and it really made me
feel like it was back in like a bug's
life days where nobody knew what they
were doing like we were all kind of like
i don't know like i guess we had to
figure it out and i
while it was super challenging it was so
rewarding to watch a crew and it and it
really does gel a crew together when
they're trying collectively to figure
out how to
how to how to overcome something um that
is as challenging obviously as working
from home was um
so i while it was really hard it was
also so rewarding and this crew really
bonded and you know the fact that we
were telling a story about the messiness
of life and meanwhile we are literally
seeing everybody's mess in their lives
behind them live and in color every day
it kind of made everybody's defenses go
down and brought a lot of their failures
and mistakes and you know moments this
is who i am like this is it
see my failures right here in front of
you um
i don't know i think there was something
really special about it too that's an
amazing story and i i really i mean the
final product definitely shows like how
much hard work you guys put into it and
how much you know it really developed
and i i think that one of the funniest i
mean one of the funniest things about
this is that it's so unapologetically
in love with toronto which i thought was
like so enjoyable
uh domi can you talk about
why you chose toronto as a setting and
you know is it just because you have
this love for toronto or is it you know
was there another purpose behind it yeah
um
i mean i i grew up in toronto i love
toronto i feel like toronto isn't really
ever seen in movies or if it is it's
always pretending to be new york or like
some fancy american city uh
and uh
i just love the diversity of toronto too
and i thought it
it was really exciting for me to
to put that on the on the big screen and
kind of share with with audiences the
neighborhoods that i grew up in the
friend groups that i had the school that
i went to and like what my classmates
all like looked and felt like and uh
it was just like i was just really
really excited just to
to put it on the big screen also there's
like i don't know like americans find a
quirkiness to canadian things so when i
pitched the movie i was like it said in
toronto and they're like oh
how how quirky how strange
canada my favorite my favorite discovery
of this whole thing
about canada was that the grading system
is different like underneath mae's bed
when she's going through all this stuff
and you see some papers on the side if
you watch it carefully there's some
papers on the side that obviously show
she is no longer an a student right and
it said something originally it had like
75 percent and it said
b
and
american i was like hold up
i got some 75 in my time
that is not a b you got that as a note i
was like that is a c so seriously there
is clearly something and then all the
canadians are like
and i was like oh i said no no no that's
a that's a b in canada and i was like
are you mean to tell me that i could
have been a straight a student if i was
in canada yeah yeah i was an a student i
had 80s what 80s thrilled oh my god mind
blowing
blowing
so any kids out there who are like my
grades aren't really good just be like
you know what in canada i'd be a
straight a student yeah come to canada
come to canada
get your report card
that's amazing i cannot believe this i'm
also feeling a little robbed right now
i feel punished and robbed frankly i
felt dumber knowing that like i was like
wait i was an american c
and b student this whole time yes the
answer is yes oh no
well thank you so much for talking to me
about this movie i can't wait for
everybody to go see it i just i watch it
twice absolutely in love with it like i
said uh thank you so much for speaking
with me and talking with collider have a
nice day thank you